. Why don't we go next? We have a little bit
of time left and we could we could talk to some
more people. Let's go to John from Orange
County, California. What's going on, John?
Hey, David. Yes, I can.
OK, well, basically.
I just wanted to get your thoughts
about. The future of Georgia
in terms of like national elections in the future
is. I've heard from Sam Ceder and his crew that.
These these ideas about if it's going
to become a battleground state or not,
and that's something that I thought would be
an interesting topic to hear you talk about.
Yeah, we've addressed this a
number of times. Demographically,
there seems to be evidence that points to
Georgia being a more reliable purple state.
Certainly what happened in twenty twenty. Joe
Biden won. Two Republican incumbent senators
were unseated by two Democratic challengers.
There's every indication that this could be a
permanent swing state rather than the
mostly reliable red state. I think 20,
22 will give us a little bit of a signal
and then 20, 20 for maybe more of one.
Right, right, and sort of, I guess, a follow up
to that and this and this thing is an interesting
question is why do you think that change happened?
And I know that. Part of that reason is probably
due to the Trump administration, but just.
Demographics and voter registration,
two things have gone on in Georgia, people
moving to Georgia that are more left leaning
and people like Stacey Abrams and others getting
left leaning, people who may not be engaged with
the political system registered and out to vote.
Right, right. I see. OK.
They did just John, I have to ask, were you
slapping something while you were talking to me?
No, you weren't interested. I was interesting.
All right, John, thank you very much for the call.
Yeah, all right, very good, John, from
Orange County, California. All right,
everybody, that's all the time I
have for calls today. I'm sorry.
I am sorry I wasn't able to get to
everybody, but I will take calls again.